my dad said he wouldn't give me a job so
I had to show him right right so I got a
job and I coordinated an AFI movie there
was a $250,000 grant and then wended a
couple couple movies for Oscar comet Raj
who then went on to become pretty big
producer yeah but the days that he was
doing small indie so yeah Wow and so did
you ever go and get your degree or you
you know you know I always I kept
working I went to I want to go back to
to study we went back to UCLA because I
kept yeah I started I started writing
and I thought got I'm a big fat liar
right I don't really know what I'm doing
so I went and took a class and I still
felt like I didn't know what I was doing
but then at the end of the semester the
professor asked me to come and be his TA
and I kind of went okay if I'm lying to
you and pulling it off I don't need to
be here I need to be some either with
somebody who calls me on my lie that I
don't know what I'm doing or just keep
writing
so just kept on writing and everybody
that I talked about a lot of friends at
that point who were in grad school for
film who said listen if if you're not
planning to direct which I never was you
know your best experience is on the
ground you know read a lot of scripts
talk to a lot of people you know go
learn how to make movies rather than
have this fantastical ideas of what it
is I won me you know kept kept working
in production wrote a script was lucky
enough to get at option then sold had a
big agency packaging it find out and
found out I didn't want to be a writer
which I consider the greatest gift of my
life
well you had said that you enjoy giving
notes but it was tougher to receive them
I was I I think I had to do with youth I
think I also had to do with my idea of
the process from the writer side that
didn't mesh up with reality
I like developing material I have a
problem especially in the 90s you know
it was a time where anybody could be a
development executive and so you had
development executives that weren't
necessarily qualified who would give you
notes about a movie in small town
America
well maybe we can do this in Mexico can
it be a Mexican family because I always
want to go to Mexico on vacation so
maybe we could go live there for a few
months and you just go wow what am I
supposed to do with that you know so it
was I didn't enjoy it I didn't enjoy
creativity by consensus a lot of my
writers loved it
and I can certainly help them navigate
through it for me it wasn't the thing I
would much rather develop material and
work with writers than be the writer to
me that was just a miserable experience
doesn't manse miss a rule for anybody
else but for me it just wasn't a fit so
I was lucky enough to know enough people
to be able to quickly make the
transition into development and start
developing material do you think that
because you didn't have the pressure of
student loans that a lot of people that
come here and I'm talking I also left at
17 and don't have a degree and so I have
the similar background in that sense and
you don't have the pressure of student
loans and having to pay those off that
you're able to do with stuff that's a
little more creative and free um yeah
but I also you know I was I was
independent at a very early age so for
me it was rent for me it was
self-sustaining I didn't you know my
parents were very much about we want you
to stand on your own two feet which was
fantastic
I think it gave me freedom but I also
honestly I very rarely see people make
choices specifically because of their
student loans I wish they made more
choices that were that would directly
influence that you know but my
experience was with film was always you
know you can study film appreciation you
need to see all the classics and I've
taken those classes over the years you
know at nauseam but for me film and
filmmaking is a very practical
experience so being on the ground that
was what I did it it wasn't you know I
didn't want to take on the student loan
or or any of those things
it just really wasn't something that
attracted me I kind of felt like why
stop this train right of going out there
and making movies and being in the
industry and making contacts and being
part of it to go be in school and a
make-believe world of let's pretend that
we're gonna write something that's going
to end up on the screen most films most
screenplays that are written in academia
and never see
the light of days most movies that are
you never make a feature in college I
made features all the time I mean I
pretty I was production coordinator
production manager on them but that was
the world that I live in so for me it
always felt like if I'm already in it
and I can take these classes between
shoots and at night and go to film
appreciation in film history and study
Gaddar and Fellini and and you know all
of those great filmmakers and understand
shot composition and directing rules and
all of those things why do I need to
stop why do I need to stop and go back
to college for four years at scene it
felt to me then like a step back of
course it's great to have a degree but I
don't find that in filmmaking
specifically for writers a degree in
screenwriting is what makes a career I
actually feel that film school is a lot
more important for directors because you
get that short you get those connections
you get you get to be you know the top
short at USC or at UCLA or at Columbia
College or you know NYU it really is a
place for a director to kind of cut his
teeth and and get a quality short
together then again and I will argue
that said because I'm a Gemini so that
duality is always warring in this day
and age with the access to digital
filmmaking you can make a great short
anywhere but I do think the directors
need more incubating and considering how
to storyboard something why do you
storyboard it that way what are the
choices that you're making a director
what is the color composition of the
shot all of those things I think that
falls into play a lot more in film
school than than writing for writers I
think that I used to make a greater
impact going to going through film
school with a focus on screenwriting and
then it does today
you